today we are going to do what it's
really like to be on take me out the
fear of every man that goes on taking
now is getting a blackout don't fall out
of the love left don't say anything
overtly racist and don't [ __ ] yourself
as long as you don't do those three
things honestly man the logistics behind
a [ __ ] terrifying the love left looks
like a well-constructed safe piece of
equipment but let me tell you it is one
of the most terrifying experiences
they're a lot in my life you're not
allowed to have any more than one corona
and you have to sign a waiver saying
that you've only had one drink you get
to ask these girls one question that
question is picked already for you by
the producers and then get prepped to
the girls on my date or take me out I
did not get arrested but the police did
arrive why we'll get there I went into
[ __ ] Chris mode I distinctly remember
putting 40 euros down on the bar and
saying to the barman do as much damage
to me if you can for that money the next
thing that I remembered was waking up on
the central reservation of Tenerife
largest motorway
[Music]
welcome back I've been joined by Johnny
new surf from propane fitness
some of you may have seen that we did a
podcast what it's review like living on
love Island it did pretty well certainly
two million watch minutes so I thought
if it ain't broke don't fix it
let's try another one so today we are
going to do what it's really like to be
on take me out it's been six years since
I was on but the memory is burned ashed
into into my nostalgia so I'm not gonna
be able to get rid of it so both of you
actually seen the episode that was on
right I saw it on TV when it was on live
so my only TV that you have so ever seen
thank you probably the only thing yeah
did you watch it because I was honored
to is it just [ __ ] because you were on
yeah he had to plug the TV in the area
good by TV from a charity shop like
forget is recycle yeah so I was on
season two no season 3 season 3 episode
2 so quite early I think it's on season
10 or 11 now for anyone who doesn't know
I mean if you don't know what take me
out is where have you been living
because it's part of the mains it's like
blind dates I can model a blind date now
isn't it although there is it blind date
yeah nobody good those are silly what
I've died or something
yeah Cilla black passed away another
John Paul Paul or Grady I think yeah the
only reason they got him is because he's
also scouts all right like you know
there's other sit-outs people out there
for anyway so prejudiced I said on the
love island podcast that I would be able
to create a framework for anybody who
wanted to get onto reality TV and that
my appearance on love island was
preceded and aided by my appearance on
taking out and if you have a look at
some of the guys who've been on take me
out they've actually gone on to have
fairly good careers in TV Ashley Cain
who was on X on the beach and is now
like MTV host in his own right and
like that like he cut his teeth so to
speak on taking out like that was his
first foray into foreign into TV so this
one I actually got picked up by my
modeling agency
so time tease put me forward for it and
you kind of you skip past the first
couple of like are you a human can you
use a keyboard like you get past those
first few like what what's 9 plus 2 yeah
well that's what yeah lady literally
just to catch the code for the result
thank ya that's it
I know you a robot take the box so the
casting process is quite interesting for
taking out because you have to basically
do a fake take me out and they hold up
cards of like different girls and you
have to choose different girls and then
they roleplay why it would be like being
on the show with you okay
which is pretty cool so you pretend to
be the girls that are on the cards yes
pretty much yeah do not on the silly
voice behind the card no it's not that
immersive which actually makes it more
difficult on everyone especially don't
be going so yeah got selected to be on a
particular season I actually found out
on the way down to Maidstone in Kent
which is where it's filmed I found out
that to a pair of twins the my really
good mates Henry in will were also going
down and were on my episode so I got
down there and I knew both of these guys
one of the works for voodoo in Leeds and
the other one worked for a competitor
company in Newcastle I was good mates
with him so it's basically like a lads
holiday for four days so they're set up
for anyone who doesn't know the setup of
taking out is when you're filming they
film back to back to back so it's aired
I think it's on a Saturday night and
it's aired weekly but the girls that are
there and the audience and Patti are
just there for however many weeks is
that's however many days they're that
Wow so it gets filmed the honesty man
that logistics behind it [ __ ]
terrifying so day one as a guy day one
travel down stay overnight
day to morning and daytime go and see
the set meet Patti practice what's going
to go on like the walk down the lovely
another bits and pieces which are bound
to shortly the love liftman evening if
they to presuming that you don't get
blackout evening of day to go to hotel
near the airport morning of day three
get on play evening of day three land
wherever is the Isle of Fernando's stay
overnight morning of day four due date
evening if they for do taking out the
gossip morning of morning of day five
fly back to the UK and [ __ ] off but what
you have to remember is because it's
back to back what every day one is
someone else's day two it's someone
else's day three this is a constantly
constantly moving it must be a
logistical nightmare it's how do they
make sure that everyone seems fresh you
can't be late for anything like it's
relentless Safari me if I'm a woman on
tape me out that means that I'm one of
the girls yeah yeah so that so they
they're on every episode yes until they
get picked picked or the series finishes
here so they could be on ten days in a
row yeah but in every single episode
they've got it'd be like I I am really
excited so every the girls have got the
roughest job of anybody because the
amount of girls there are which i think
is twenty
maybe twenty this is rude maybe twenty
and they have to get their hair and
makeup done I think the hair and makeup
teams only many two people two or three
people the girls
remembering that we begin filming at
five or six o'clock at night on that day
- mm-hmm the girls start getting their
hair and makeup done at 9:00 a.m. and
they're on a rotation thing so if you
went first yesterday you get to go that
middle-of-the-pack tomorrow but there's
some girls that have been sat with a
full face of makeup and their hair done
from like 10:30 in the morning until
5:00 p.m. just watching all of their
mates but they're all staying in the
same hotel and they're all getting on
and like having jokes and laughs and
stuff like that says I guess it's not
too bad but I don't envy the job of the
girls you just have to turn at once and
you either don't go back run again or
you
yeah the guy is very it's probably quite
symbolic for how men deal with more low
investment I'm either in or I'm out yet
if your eyes you've run away curl up in
a ball don't speak to anyone again
that's it away you go so yeah the
speaking of that if if you're out the
the fear of every man that goes on
taking you now he's getting a blackout
mmm like it is you just terrified should
we explain the format of the show for
people we just gonna assume let's go
from start to finish so you arrive on
the morning go and meet paddy McGuinness
who is the coolest guy on the planet by
the way like you can breakdance he does
karate and he's got a Bolton accent I
mean like he's the big three is the big
worry yeah and his missus is
unbelievable does he get her through
that take me out for a so he didn't I
don't think which is his hobbies have to
host and be they can even be running
between blow be the best idea of the
show yeah well putting McGuinness with
my identity crisis okay yeah multiple
identity missing my wife all as a result
of this process so you're just going on
with it believe in it
because I can trust the trust approach
so you gets real on the morning my
schizophrenic show to what no I can't
explode it in so you going during the
day and you get to meet Patti and what's
kind of cool is because you're the only
person who's out on that stage in front
of the girls right and if it's 20 on one
and if you if one of the girls has a bit
of a pop at you it'll give you one or
two seconds to say something and if you
don't come up with something
he'll just throw a zinger in imma be
saying that he's got you back like he's
the it's too it's actually to 120 but
Patty's like the power of 20 women so
he's able to kind of mask his stuff is
inscripted no it's just a messy modem
believably wedding yeah this is just I
think because it the goal of taking out
is to be as cheesy as possible but they
want the most one either at home i lover
not a fighter but if you can throw
cliches it
love it that's what they want literally
laughing so yeah you're going during the
day I remember on my one there's an a
southern Irish guy called Paul and he
was gonna have to shear a live sheep oh
so you had to get we've got these like
train stage cheeping but they've got
their own trailer and this I killer
honestly I couldn't believe it
there was a little square drawn in like
spray paint you know good spray paint
the sheep with to kill them
that's what you're gonna shave and he's
in practicing shaving his sheep doesn't
like it all and it's like running away
Paddy's just oh this is the most real
thing cuz they train sheep TV she said
there's a guy who trains them he keeps
them rents them out you know he's the
handler as well he's making a full-time
income from rennet if she could make me
pulling her but when he when he came in
he was actually become as he take from
the Sheep like a lot of grain on
whichever [ __ ] there was he came in and
he was extolling the virtues of the like
discography the filmography that they
paid I was like was on Emmerdale couple
weeks ago I was in the background of the
most recent film with Sasha Baron Cohen
in it and I seen the Royale yeah you won
what's a male sheep just a sheep run Ram
Robert is a man that knows his trade
then like but he knows I'm sure anyway
you spend a day and they're like oh so
you're gonna come down and you get in
the love liftin this is what's gonna
happen it's kind of be hurried because
it's four of you right and there's loads
of other [ __ ] like you are not really
the highest priority to dieter
don't fall out of the love lift don't
say anything
overtly racist and don't [ __ ] yourself
like as long as you don't do those three
things broadly gonna be okay and it's oh
here I'll get onto the main bit right so
it was your love left like what do you
mean
look do you do anything bad and love
left or he was just a little bit it was
yeah buddy we can see Chris in the
lovely what we can't get the fridge
video video video man team will try
find the footage we are going to try and
track it down there will be photos of me
appearing around with an afro yeah
cuz I'm not for them anyway my friend so
you start off on the nighttime and the
audience the load it's aired to about 4
million people and you don't give a [ __ ]
about the 4 million people but you're
terrified of the 250 that are live in
the audience right 250 people watching a
TV show all excited by paddy McGuinness
is loud so that [ __ ] there behind you so
the way that we start so you can imagine
that the studio is quite circular and
you come in from the back behind them
and then you walk around to the edge all
the way to the back of the love lift so
you're walking behind the girls
basically but there's a big wall so you
can't really see what's going on but you
can really [ __ ] hear what's going on
and Paddy there's a an entertainer a
comedian that comes on in between it's
actually probably a pretty good evening
out to go and see that you get to watch
your TV and you get to see comedian and
this padding of Guinness comes out and
wants everyone up a little bit and I was
like third person I think so I've got to
hear like hey and then the guy before we
got a black out and I'm like oh my god
right it's gonna happen it's gonna
happen and you're not allowed to have
any more than one corona and you have to
sign a waiver saying you've only had one
drink because some guy did something and
go embarrassed and accused itv of
loading him up with booze this was only
season 3 when I was on and some guy
would in the first two seasons had
already dragged them into some litigated
nightmare in an effort to try and
discount the fact that he was [ __ ] on
camera I don't know when white gonna but
you're allowed a corona and you really
let the final the last drop okay now see
you walk because if this sounds cheap it
now and I really think about it but I I
imagined that everyone's kind of waiting
in this sort of upper studio and they
will come down the lift that's what
happens right no so the first time they
walk in and come around so you walk in
and go right around the back and not
and the comedian whatever will be on at
this point cuz you're gonna be in
between - right and then you'll get in
and you walk of a spiral staircase and I
know that from the front the love left
looks like a well-constructed
yeah and safe piece of equipment but let
me tell you it is one of the most
terrifying experiences they're a lot in
my life
like it is just cables that are
incredibly thin and very wobbly and then
you step on and you have to wait until
the whole point of the love lift is that
you have to wait until it hits the
bottom and then you take your first step
because otherwise you're basically just
gonna so that's a point one if don't
fall out the lovely okay and then you
don't poo yourself don't do anything
overtly racist so it's not that they're
taking you over the full spectrum of
fears so like fear fear of death when
you're in the lovely reject you get out
and the fear of rejection from the women
and then like the the instant like 250
people yeah fear intimidation making a
fool of yourself intimidation yeah it's
it's a very very nerve-wracking
environment to be in and let's say you
don't think about the cameras because
the cameras are just they're miles away
from you they're all on it's those guys
like fat lads that sit down a bit swivel
walk Ric it's not people walking around
with it not really you don't notice that
as much but anyway so you're at the top
of the love lift and they'll be counting
you in and then your music starts and
you have to choose a song set to submit
a song and this was when I was 24 so I
was right in the midst of being promoted
a wanker so I was like oh yeah Jamie
Jones hungry for the power it's like we
can't have any techno tech house how
about example love kickstart again and
I'm like fine okay so like and their
love kicks that's completely not what
you choose but if we get popped on
YouTube for me he says I was pitch was -
anyway you're coming down and you step
off and you've already been given the
points that you walk - you walk to the
left new wave of the girls you walk to
the right and you wait for the girls and
you walk to the middle and you turn
around you got
hello girls my name is Chris and I'm
from Newcastle so Joanne what do you
think of Chris and it goes on like that
and you're like right okay once you once
you've kind of said the first thing and
you've got you first little forwards and
back to you
he's pretty sweet have they got a chance
to blackout during that yeah yes so not
during that but basically they get they
get first first impressions and here's
like one of the secrets have taken me
out so it's kind of a [ __ ] bit of the
show all of the girls are really really
aware that the longer that they keep
their light off the more episodes
they're going to be on if they get taken
on a date after one more episode on TV
that's that game over so have a look
early in the season early in the season
that girls a boom or didn't like the way
that you crossed the road there mmm
Oh boom like any excuse to turn off
because they want to so the producers
actually hot to push the girls I look
like you've been - you make me too
difficult for the guys so early on in
the season precisely it's a lot it's a
prisoner's dilemma because there the
incentives are aligned there and as you
said they can get they for them to
prolong their think they can forego the
chance of being on a date yeah which
completely just ruins the point of the
show right here show you exactly so they
have to say look you need to need to
keep your light on all right okay so
you're aware of that as a guy is while
you go on and you've heard this style
right - this I'm on Episode two or three
by memory no man yeah it's so difficult
so anyway you come down and they they
get to boo-boo and I think I lost like
one light or two lights at the very
start you kind of good considering I do
you know that's why patty patty goes
over any girls so Jemma you turned your
light off but oh well you know I just I
don't like someone let's go bigger than
me or whatever it is it is there's
anything I don't like something
something arbitrary right like something
completely arbitrary but anyway so they
do that and you start moving through is
not like I don't
then you have to get him all 250 people
in a crowd to sign an NDA waiver right
start again
no reaks is there something normal but
you didn't exactly and so yeah I need to
start back and forth and you have your
VT I'm Chris and I do this than the
other and whatever in the VT videotape
Aaron refusing a ticket I thought VT was
gonna be like a sort of an industry term
they get to videotape videotape me yeah
so you do your VT you've already filmed
this like four weeks in advance so they
come up and they just try and follow you
around and let me try and recall some of
this it was like my name is Chris on the
face of it I'm a club promoter I do all
this stuff but actually deep down I'm a
bit of a nerd and I like to read Game of
Thrones with my mates and there's like a
cut to like picture of you read I
remember books with mates yeah on an
l-shaped sofa you know what it was then
what they want to do they don't want
anyone to have to polish they were like
a personal or a persona that they put
across they don't have a [ __ ] in the
armor exactly so for me they were like I
was like I was reading getting in front
and that right okay so you need to come
in and sit down and say to the people in
the room that you really excited cuz the
Dragons have started fighting and I was
like don't be pedantic here but this is
the second book in Game of Thrones and
the dragons haven't hatched yet it's not
even like I wouldn't do that I'm not
yeah so that but they have to throw
something in it that - just give it a
little bit of levels and didn't lose a
single light the Dragons didn't lose a
single one so yeah anyway and then they
do that and like sometimes go off for me
they didn't and they go back round and
their talk to more of the girls and all
the time you're watching your VT for the
first time on is huge so the big screen
that you see above the thing that
videoed from above the crowd is only
what you're watching you on that's not
superimposed so you got stood there like
a need
watching an IMAX video of yourself
whilst trying not to crumble right and
then it cuts back and they ask you some
more questions in this back and forth
with the girls and stuff in all this
time you're thinking like first off [ __ ]
please don't press the button because I
don't a blackout but that that
overarching fear is so comprehensive
that it doesn't permit you to really use
any judgement so you know like robbing
the house in a bidding a car crash and
you can't remember what happened in the
finer points yeah the fight or flight is
kicked in to such a degree that your
ability to fine-tune your vision goes
out the window so all you see is like
Gobbo things
it's like blonde brunette like paddy
McGuinness its Tamra man but you just
know I make my version that's the thing
so you just see the lego version of each
person and you just global feel oh yeah
so and then they keep on keep on going
from there you have a little bit more
back and forth and Patti will come in
and out and stuff but what you have to
remember is it although you may see in
between each round you'll get to see
maybe one or two answers from the girls
they'll go to ten and then they'll pick
the top few see so there's even so do
you remember watching you thinking
everyone's really like quick on yeah
someone when someone bumbles it there is
it yeah they'll just do what they'll
just go to someone else and until they
get a couple of the off they're the
subject of it for a lot longer than it
seems yeah because it seems so like
production buying like it Chris right
when you go off you go some races to mmm
but you're there for quiet money goes a
patty will come over and he'll say so
like what do you what do you think
something like that ago Chris has told
me what he thinks but first back to the
brig and he'll cut to the break and then
you just stood there like it lemon
is there a mistake and then
fifteen I would be good during the break
like just stop the reset stuff and
they'll get ready for like double check
with camera shake some it's live yes
right if the whole thing is live and the
problem is that you're not really us no
I know it's not live it's not
broadcasted live
that's like saying are these vegetables
fresh well yeah they would do a freshman
of a frozen originally it's not live no
but they cut to the break so that it is
chopped up ready for it to be brought
around I guess a so I'll cut away and
you stood there and then they'll be a
little bit back and forth and that's
when you turn around and you see the
crowd and you're like so I'm sorry of
course it's not live just said four but
like if they thought they are they
Terrence's of me they sing about the
best one oh I see yeah so they're doing
that life I want to know what software
that you do but they've got the guy with
the oculus rift in the iPod the trouble
you know penny about D to do yes who is
the most comprehensive video usually huh
I feel like video Mon Dean's listening
to this thinking like okay oh my god
they cut out the best bit so yeah you
you've done you next bit and then yeah
my business partner came on Darren and
he told four million people that my mom
still does my washing but as a part of
that
anyone who's met Darren did you guys
agree on the the thing that he would say
to like rip you know so you had to agree
that basically in advance so you have to
you have to give them a bunch of
information and then they're gonna come
in with something say like oh like I
really like feet or I never clean my
room or I do whatever whatever and they
try and come up with a bunch of stuff
cuz I suppose the risk is they say
something really savage and like I've
been mates with Chris for a while he's
actually I'm a pedophile but not
I think that's not so much that's like
dancing yeah yeah operation you tree you
know we have one light left of it I
think it's just like we yeah I think
it's handcuffs yeah and Chris gets taken
away very quickly let me go so it's not
that and yeah
Darren got asked to say the words but
Chris's mom always does his washing so
he always stays box fresh and it took
them 15 takes
diffuser so I'm not saying that whose he
kept on saying different that none of
Darin Darin it's the line is so he
always stays box fresh what wouldn't say
that no Darren Darren we need we need
you to say so he always stays okay okay
okay go again
so he always stays fresh no Darin Darin
can we go and eventually but with this
and fresh so I'm the the buttery biscuit
base video you see Matt yeah the old
couple the guy has to say buttery
biscuit base and he gets it wrong and I
was that's not but Darren elected to get
it wrong right he was just like I'm just
not saying it yeah that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
Darren from my perception from my
perspective just seems zero [ __ ]
like he's just got no time for fluff or
fanfare and he's being made to say all
these things by a bunch of by a bunch of
TV studio intimidating people who sound
like me so anyway um and he said that
and more like to go off or whatever and
then you get yeah oh you've got yourself
a dude once you realize it's a guy that
you've got yourself a date once you've
got past all of those things cuz the
girls will still get to say things to
you after you've done so why did you
turn your light off but you know that
you've got yourself a date night is that
because once there's a certain number of
stages they have to they're locked in
yes they yeah exactly so they've
committed to the purchase they first Add
to Cart and they've committed to me
potentially being in their cart okay and
the one in their car details yet like
yeah they pressed it the press play
securely they've gone through all the
authorization I'm just love selling them
that right than the order form isn't
work
that's what some of them experienced
yeah it isn't so one of the things is
once you've got to that stage in any
guys who were going under taking out
once you get to that stage you are
allowed to completely unload because
inevitably some of the girls to turn the
lighter oh I just really don't think
these or whatever this the other you can
say whatever you want to them now it
won't be on TV so the the main bit the
main thing that I want to get across to
everybody that's watching is ever seen
take me out
is the sheer distance from you to all of
the girls that are that because it'll
distance yes like just I know that it
looks especially the ones that are in
the front
okay maybe ten yards ten yards away as
you start panning around towards the
edges there you're talking about twenty
twenty-five yards away I did think that
when I watched it actually are you
running over to the gun you remember the
bleep test of school turning off the
lights of the girls is akin to the bleep
turn right you get a lucozade halfway
through and there's a masseuse that
gives you a rubdown Oreo segment yeah so
the it is so far from where you're stood
to where the girls are and trying to
decipher the granular elements of a
girls look in personality from the ten
seconds that she's got to speak at
twenty yards distance is less rub it in
headlights mode oh because it cuz it's a
Lego woman it's just learning it is a
perfect storm of error making so can you
remember the because what I'm most
interested in is the sequence of what
happens so like this rounds how many
rounds three like three so they so like
humming lights went off in each round
and then you are left with a choice I
was left with eleven at the end another
so how did you make the decision suppose
during the show you're not really
assessing the women you were thinking of
like how can I not to have a black up
yeah that's the thing that it's like a
false positive or whatever it's like
you're searching for the wrong that
you're hoping that the wrong thing
doesn't have
not that the right thing does mm-hmm
you're limiting damage rather than
maximizing block sizes yeah because you
just terrified and fear pervades like
everything else yeah yeah doesn't like
you take on TV don't look like on TV oh
yeah so yeah turned off and then had to
choice between two girls and one of them
was no start so hold on so there's a
legend yeah
so in how long like 20 seconds 20
seconds probably it's just pure instinct
yeah like because yeah just press some
press and press some of the ones that
said weird things press because it under
that as well because you just run around
it looked like you were just
thoughtlessly but lose many people Oh
sleep was I see you've got it so to make
a choice out 11 because once you tend
someone's like oh and you can't go back
up undo I think the end rules are like
you can't if you go from left to right I
might go like oh yeah so like you
thought you go like you have a scan
first but they know that the eyes are on
you see you don't wanna be too judging
you just rotate yourself to the left for
me please did you do sudden talk do
suddent no happy but wistful is yeah no
yeah no no nothing me and you just think
right okay you can't get them to say
anything anymore because all the crowds
going really right well cuz this is the
family of lot of course girls are there
so it's like it's basically saying your
daughter's pig-ugly
or boring in front of everyone she's had
a cares about that the girls have got
themselves to that stage and they like
you've not allowed them to get there
this is the only time where you exercise
any level of decision so like this is
the chance for them to looks good yeah
to pay back in fact it's worse because
you're like if they say no you're like
fair enough like I came on the show
that's a risk if I they put myself out
there was a girl and let myself get to
the last run I've still got my light on
and you turn me off yeah that's part of
your [ __ ] is they fat middle thing you
have to leave one on Oh has anyone just
gone in turned more often be like ah
[ __ ] this
yeah that seems a good product she so
for me that might have been that would
have been the best option
Wow that would have been the safest
option the safest well just the FAMAS
sanity Chris what happened I managed to
pick I'm gonna be as diplomatic as
possible yeah I'm I need you to pick a
girl who she wasn't the most interesting
I'm gonna remain diplomatic until later
on okay so I have a fantastic my dating
history is awash with girls me picking
girls are really bad for me and take me
out was no different bad like you gained
a bit of weight like what do you mean my
father me developed a cocaine habit yeah
no it was just that she was broadly she
was really dull right and so you want to
talk about like anything well just
what's gonna happen when AI takes over
the world no no no this was this was
Chris at 24 I was perfectly happy just
talking about like what she did for fun
or what a favorite cocktail was right
and there was one point where the
conversation had got down to how her dad
once took her crabbing not like she's
gonna see this and she is she's gonna
see maybe she's not I don't care about
the Internet's a big place nothing like
the Internet is a big position it's
because if I was in your position I'd be
thinking like I'll go spare her feelings
we didn't have a if you do picture a
Venn diagram it's anyway if anyone if
anyone's seen the episode why so many
episodes of damning enough is it is okay
and then when I went on taking out she
sold a story about me - ah - like reveal
magazine video man Dean will make it
appear here I think video might need you
go hunt it down and that's a horrendous
so she just saw the story so the story
that so Khalifa literally boring yes so
haughty Chris I'm gonna no no don't you
worry I'm gonna come back we'll leave
back to this she's so using this on
Facebook so you've got that for ten days
ten more puns and we'll pay for doors
just so you know the story headline
that was revealed in reveal was the
police got called on my date with Chris
broadly true for sure but like because
like there was something going on no no
this is amazing the police got called
for me
and us for you or by you for me to get
you to get me so so when you say the
police were called that's broadly true
to me that's very much like either the
police without the police weren't points
for that who called the police the
police got called to my date with Chris
the reason that's not true is because
she wasn't there but I was so I'd left
her I mean you and I didn't get arrested
it didn't get arrested on my date on
take me out I did not get arrested but
the police did arrive why we'll get to
that you can after the break after a
message from our sponsor yeah
so we're just gonna be using pants
mm-hmm that's not a sponsor anyway so
you fight you you go down to the last
two and then what they've done so you'll
remember I'm taking out they have the
question and they're like you get to ask
these girls one question right that
question is picked already for you by
the producers and then gets prepped to
the girls they don't know which guides
gonna design request I've always
wondered that because they got signals
right yeah they've got absolute like
belters I can't remember what my
question was
so I've maybe like what's your best
feature or something like that's gonna
be horse eyes don't exercise for that if
anyone finds herself in this position
horse I would you rather be a horse
sized duck or a duck sized horse they
call the dark dark question no no yes no
no did we stop that you can't save us
not even this is a PG at this is a PG
episode okay right so anyway Duncan
horse you've got it you've got to choose
one of the girls at the end and you kind
of have to do though like faint and
pretend that you're doing one and then I
say pick the other and within five
seconds of pressing the button of the
other girl I realize that make a mistake
or what just instinct that she didn't
like do anything she's like stop turning
when you press the button us no no right
it was but it was it was an error and as
I walked up the stairs some of the mates
of one of the other lads that was on
that was going we're looking
we going how's that hmm yeah this is
maybe an error so and then they ask you
at the end who was the person you were
going to pick look love at first light
they don't have that anymore
I'm sorry they didn't have that when I
was lower first light wasn't a thing
when I was on more shame I've never
heard of that it's like when they see
the lineup and they have to pick someone
before it okay okay filets I like an
extra feature in the mid like two point
one yeah because I that was the only
episode of take me obviously so know
that that didn't happen had they have
done that that would have been I would
have been able to say but later on I had
sex with that girl in any case so it
didn't sound so I found that go on
Facebook the night I arrived in the
hotel in Fernando's before it even been
on the date with the main go so the girl
that you turn you just turned on like no
no she turns her light off for me found
her on Facebook message to start humming
it back and forth before I read that's a
big [ __ ] you isn't it like she turned a
light off but you got her anyway yeah
I'm right at it should we just dropped
us at the top so the crisp on the front
so what now it gets on to the fun stuff
right so this is the this is the best
like most interesting bits about the
production as far as I'm concerned so
you meet Patti I have me meet your date
for the thing anything and then they get
you to walk off you're off to the I love
fernando lores and you walk up and you
get to the top and you turn around you
wait and then you go down the steps and
as you're going down there's always a
camera backstage as you start curling
down and you kids from the cheek and so
she looks literally or whatever and then
at the bottom of that set steps there
are two runners they're like right don't
look at go that way you don't look at
him go that way and that is the last
time that you see that girl until when
you are in the aisle on the other
Fernando's and they appear from behind
you and go hi yeah we're ready to go
dune buggying
you look lovely and then you walked away
that's the next time you see them so
there's no prep then it's it's that's a
fresh reaction when she's like so from
from that moment where you get to the
bottom
the steps any part ways you go to
separate hotels next to different
airports well I went to Luton she went
to like Stansted or Gatwick or something
you then got on different flights stay
in different hotels in fernando's which
the years I was on it was Tenerife so
that's I have to let the project manager
for videos when I'm believable the there
must be a reason why they do that
because they don't want so the reason
that they don't allow you and your date
to look each other or ever interact
off-camera is because if you say
something that's offensive or funny or
cute her reaction to you is going to
change but the justification so that
hasn't been captured on camera so
there's a break in the storyline does
that make sense so just the continuity
yeah pretty much so they just don't want
you or her to get anything to know
anything about each other without them
being without them being without you
being completely constructed and I think
considering I said that loved islands
are very holistic kind of natural
manifestation of people's emotions and
it's not really saddled with all that
much take me out they don't ever script
what you're saying they allow you to
have natural reactions but it's a lot
more highly produced and they because of
this really alien nature of it just
being two of you and the [ __ ] film
troupe of people around you and you've
got these runners so yeah you get down
to the bottom of the stairs and they're
like don't look at her go the other way
and then you part wait go to our town
the night with the other guys that
potentially go date if they got a date
and then stay overnight
gabs the next morning you get on the
plane fly out spend the afternoon in
Tenerife getting a tan and showing out
go to sleep and then the cult are still
not with no dough not choosing a
different hotel out there as well
different call time in the morning so
you get up in the morning it's like one
of the guys I was the last day and I was
up at heart six the first day was up at
five in the morning
crazy so there's a film crew out there
that are just receiving these parcels
that you know like a t-shirt firing gun
like button boom just being shot out of
the studio inmates
and then these guys are just like
catching P couples and then going okay
so we're gonna go
so anyway got out there and you have the
SAP thing where you're gonna meet them
on the morning and they come higher and
it turned out that our date was going to
be deep-sea fishing which is naturally
not tremendously exciting date to be on
and unfortunately that wasn't aided by
the girl that was on it with three nice
a deep-sea fishing that's not you
that's like--that's with it that's off
the back of a boat yeah on that big sigh
kind of wouldn't a Spanish wooden boat
thing with a full crew this than the
other in any way yeah Theo the crews
circling around and a speedboat and
you're cutting in between and after
you've done stuff so I got really bored
like the conversation I had with her was
about as dollars it could have been I
had a dirty non I'd make it made a
mistake sighs all right [ __ ] it this was
the final day before freshers week right
so the freshest week to me was beginning
the next day which is just the beginning
of me being very very slowly fisted
mm-hmm behind 8,000 students is that
right I am going to [ __ ] enjoy this
one-day holiday hey it in Tenerife no
matter what so I was just on the boat
and was so bored that took my top off
took my shorts I jumped in the sea guys
were on the boat going around filming
[ __ ] themselves and started getting on
the radio saying getting back in the
boat because they didn't have public
liability insurance for me to be in the
sea
Oh threw me loudly beyond the blow naked
as well no pants okay so I know if that
happened yeah and then you cut in
backwards and forwards so anyway we had
basically hadn't had any food all day
and it got to the evening time and it
was running quite late and I was quite
hungry and I said what can I get cases
Desperados please and so gays like Frank
case fault okay no I gay can get kiss
forgot for Desperados notice at and I
was ready in five minutes
slide the huge hair so I didn't even
have to do my hair and I'm stuck just
sipping these Desperados and you'll have
on your phone and stuff like that
my phone I text my mates will take me
over and then what beer done
two beers down three beers done on my
[ __ ] OS this bird and she's taken
ages to get ready so by the time I
finished for Desperados and I have belly
that day as well I'm incredibly merry
and feeling lucid to say the least and I
okay so we're gonna have this first off
he was going to be a dinner on a rooftop
it ended up being a glass of champagne
on the top of someone's garage why
because the first location that they
tried to use they couldn't get hold of
and then the Sun was going down because
she taken so long to get ready blah blah
blah blah so so there's no makeup
there's no like she doesn't run but did
you have makeup no interesting you don't
have makeup on most reality TV shows all
right okay anyway so we're there and
they brought out this bottle of
Fernando's champagne pop down the middle
of the table
no I there you go by the time she'd had
one glass I'd finished the remainder of
the bottle they brought another one and
I did the same thing again oh my god so
by this time I'm [ __ ] my physic cuts
to a scene of me talking into the camera
and my eyes are all blurry and red Chloe
hunk no idea what's going on LED
absolutely battered by this stage I was
like and they'd start talking to you
about all of you bits and you know that
all of your all of the people that
you're with are also on dates so I
wonder how such and such she's getting
on and we know this is going on blah
blah blah and yeah there was definitely
a residual feeling of bitterness that I
could have chosen any girl that was even
civil but she didn't she do one that I
chose was badly than that and as I feel
like I'm gonna enjoy the holiday I'm
just gonna get method she wasn't going
like chatting to you of speaking to is
just belly or like it was like getting I
said my one of the things that didn't
make the Edit is probably one of the
best lines I've ever said in my life got
it ma
was a sort of club promoter you know I
am used to early mornings and late
nights I work hard but that girl there
is the hardest days graft ever ever had
to do in my entire life
and they're like still swinging on their
dregs of this champagne so anyway you
drive back and you go meet the guys and
then what happens from there is you go
to taking out the gossip which used to
be hosted by Mark Wright and someone
else and basically that they're trying
to get you to either shag or fight
whoever it is that you're with and as I
I have no interest in doing either
nate'll I just want to be away from her
and I just want to be with snakes cuz I
had two buddies that were there and we
connected to this Paul guy who sheared a
sheep and I'm like look I'm just good to
chill out with the boys
and obviously they kind of had because
they were getting on with their girls
they kind of had that in the back of
their minds a bit but so yeah you Kate
oddly quite a nicely community-based
thing towards the end and you can t get
back together and especially if you've
had a bit of an awkward day or have you
left some respite and so you go out on
the nighttime and this is where the
police story begins to one degree or
another so I can't believe I've never
told you this I would do the police
story did this girl just not take a
liking to you specifically or do you
think it wasn't personal it was just
like I think is a Combinator's a
combination of things first off she
wasn't she wasn't making a massive
effort and she used this line of
treating me and Kiki that's a no like
just even back then even ten years ago
ish six years seven years ago I had in
the back of my mind you should just be
being yourself that you should just be
being truthful and virtuous because
that's the best way to operate and it
came across she came across terribly on
TV anyone I've heard who spots the treat
and mean line is a fundamental day it's
just a manipulative cow right it's like
well cuz it's the same kind of people
that think that are Rhys a see and it's
like no no you just knob yeah so it
worked out really bad that she deleted
her
Twitter account because she got a little
bit we'll say it a little bit because of
the way that she'd gone on anyway so
when on the day went on the night out
later on in the evening the one you have
sex or fight with the person you with in
our life not bothered they give you a 50
euros allowance and they basically put
you in a bar and allow it to be as
natural as possible any kind of is also
what's really funny is to see the
difference between the crew and the kit
the ITV have and the crew and the kit
the ITV to have it's like going from the
most polished like there's a security
guy and there's a huge van and miss than
the other and it's just some dude with
like you is iPhone out desperately
hoping to caps are picking up change off
the floor you can tell with the
production quality as well when you like
when you see those like after yeah the
show it's just it's complete tronic
dredge up any of those amazing few a
toms budget so see well that's what my
phone in over there so anyway you're on
the night and she'd been doing this
thing she'd handed me a purse to like
look after as if it you know like that
sassy cape and I might as I just
couldn't person this one just put it
down on the bar and walked off that
didn't go down very well in any way
thankful thankful what happened next was
I went into [ __ ] Chris mode and I
remember distinctly remember putting 40
euros down which is why I had left 40
rows down on the bar and saying to the
barman do as much damage to me if you
can for that money that is the Pokemon
that you evolve into well yeah when
things that everyone you range to know
each other when you reach the required
amount of alcohol that's the person i
Hitmonlee guy who though shiny yeah
which is and this is exactly why I don't
drink anymore
so I've never seen that so it's a sight
to behold but I really should engineer
that and then put ice is bloody teetotal
now after our terrible alcohol podcasts
so we've yeah we've discovered it so 40
euros down and that's kind of the last
thing that I remember clearly
I remember going to an after-party with
the barman and a bunch of his friends
and then the next thing that I
remembered was waking up on the central
reservation of Tenerife so largest
motorway really at about where the suns
in the sky it's pretty warm and I've
lost my phone that didn't have any money
and because I've been looked after by
the film crew for the entire time I was
there I didn't know where I was staying
and they didn't know I was doing this so
there's not many worth places to wake up
than the sensual resumes so I'm guessing
she wasn't at the after-party you just
bet I was no no she also wasn't on the
central reservation up so otherwise it's
quite romantic yeah and we ended up on
the central reservation together no yeah
I was on the central reservation of
Tenerife largest motorway and you know
in Spain they've got those signs that
come up and go over the top of the
motorways and it's got the time and then
the temperature mmm neither of them were
good who's like 7:30 a.m. 25 degrees my
head's absolutely ringing I've got no
idea
I've lost my phone remembering this is
the first day of freshers week which
means my phone number was on every fly
we'd given out and every Facebook event
so I'm just getting pounded with
guestlist texts no way I can tell my
business partner that he needs to change
the number that's on the Facebook ha ha
no way I can contact the film crew so
I'm walking down the central reservation
this disheveled looking British tourists
covered in that red dust you get from
that Spanish islands that all down the
back of a white shirt massive afro just
looking [ __ ] like God knows why anyone
must have thought that walking now tried
to hail a taxi didn't have any money so
I have to tell hail a taxi in a language
I didn't speak then convinced them that
despite looking like someone who's
homeless with no money that I could give
them money but then realized that the
only money I had in the hotel was pounds
how much would you be able to drive me
essentially for free to this hotel for
me to give you some money in a currency
you don't use unsurprisingly is
difficult but he accepted so no I'm an
even underground carpark
gave me
coffee and felt bad for me I'm Alex IV
be able to sew as like if you say that
tape into the studio awesome but I just
needed to convince what to the man with
the iPhone I need advice I mean they
convinced the Spanish taxi driver of
anything and that's just something as
far as the ground carpet carpet as well
to your car elves are farmers have found
myself in an underground car park this
man gave me a coffee
trying to helped latte yeah I think so
flat white which is a latte caramel
latte
no no it's one of those one baking a
[ __ ] gonna look the flat way
yeah but Bank is about the choosers
literally looked like one as well
my head's absolutely killing me at this
point and I knew because of the tight
production schedule I knew that my
flight was at 10:30 so I was like right
I have now a two and a half hours to get
from wherever I am to wherever the [ __ ]
I'm supposed to be and then to the
airport no idea so anyway walking down
the side of the motorway gangs I'm just
on this motorway and the Guardia Civil
pull up which is like the military
Spanish police so the Guardia Civil pull
up like oh my friend you okay make your
party McGinnis really [ __ ] me over and
they they have been on this terrible
date with this girl honestly and they
took me back to the hotel and they were
like the armed police did basically the
Guardia Civil took me mother they were
the taxi people hope to the army took
you home took me home from Monday on
take me up the army took me home from I
don't take me up here how does she know
about that how did she know nothing I've
told everyone the story as soon as I go
back to the hotel and then including her
you fly back as a group of couples you
all fly back together so what they
thought was when they when the film crew
got back to the hotel where's Chris
Chris isn't in his room
brilliant must be with his bird wasn't
with his bird [ __ ] where's Chris he must
be with the army he must be with the
army you know exactly that's where you
were he must be in the central
reservation of Tenerife larger smoke
well it's all right the army okay what
really this happens all the time
so they came in collected me took me
back to that trying out in the hotel and
I was just like looked at the looked at
my watch as I could say nine o'clock or
something do know what I'm supposed to
do I was [ __ ] so just a head in the
pillow ten minutes later
big bang on the door and I opened it and
some one little runner was in front of
me and we've got him he's here he's here
obviously had been running around trying
to find me and it just thought as a
last-ditch attempt we'll just knock on
the door and see if he's there
got me bundle all my stuff into the taxi
had to run like the worst hangover ever
you know when you've had like two hours
sleep and you were blind drunk and
everything hurts everything's terrible
he's just tired and ratty managed to
make it onto the plane just about so
that was 10 a.m. 9:30 10:00 a.m. for our
plane back to the UK this is 2012 which
is when the London Olympics run the the
taxi from the airport to Kings Cross was
three and a half hours then the train
from Kings Cross to Newcastle it's three
and a half hours I got my suitcase out
with the Train put it into a taxi got
tax it down to the key side to Riverside
pulled it out of the taxi put it into
the boot my business partners car cause
the boot and then stood outside and
worked and that was the beginning of
freshers week so that was like a 21-hour
day with the worst hangover I've ever
ever ever had and one of the good things
about that experience is that I now feel
broadly indestructible it was like
hangover sunstroke sleep deprivation and
long flight its way it's waking up
without money phone you are no way
stayin in a central reservation yeah
there is nothing like I honestly think
like dropping the middle of the
Antarctic nap but so would laughing Bear
Grylls it because coming after that day
yeah I mean it can't be worse than that
economy stays up but I've seen you with
me in
the high street in Reykjavik and we
lasted 20 seconds that was extreme
temperatures precisely probably the
Arctic might be because but I agree that
that story is that because the the
temperature on paper was so tame yeah it
sounds like we're just being a bunch of
absolute [ __ ] well so the lesson is
pay attention to the feels-like
temperature not the temperature if you
were ever going out in Iceland as a
little bit of advice for you do not do
what me and Johnny did which is be
northern lads
I'm just wearing just wear shirts
because although the temperature saves
it only - to the feels like is minus 12
and minus 12 is really really [ __ ]
chilled yeah you thought you had
pneumonia and I got you actually had met
a guy that when he arrived with
meningitis he brought it into a good
series anything yeah I so starting to
tactic you with him you know you know
when it's the end of the night out and
you stood in a taxi queue and the taxi
you just you just think this is gonna
last for eternity like there's so many
people in front of me the rate that
taxis are coming I'm gonna die here like
one you Alan please jump yeah but still
freezing to the bone one person trying
to jump the queue in everyone absolutely
body checkup person you are not pushing
in this there's not this man in a
wheelchair it's just ready to body the
only other thing advice if you're in
Iceland is just make sure you've brought
nine and a half thousand pounds with you
it's only about 1/4 I could be able to
buy one thing yeah a sixpence every item
isn't you know and you go to a pawn shop
you're like excuse me sir how much is
this and then I that's a pound and you
know what about this and that not about
you know what if I could this and this
yeah look sir so it's like that but with
nine and a half thousand nine I think
from now on poetry sketch that we came
up with yeah yeah so have you got any
questions about take me that was a
massive dieter quite what I wanted to
ask you was how you went through the
selection but you covered that selection
process I am if enough people keep on
telling me to do a video of how to get
on reality TV
do it you'll cover it yeah I'm mighty
sorry I man selection on the way how to
pick the girl oh you weren't just
terribly just like you can't do it like
a just random if you look you try and
remember what they've said I suppose
he's not one to ask because he ended up
with a bad selection that you do not
want to save money by station yeah very
few successes um has anybody got a
blackout as soon as they arrive no in
the history of the show is that because
they're instructed to say like but then
how do you enforce that I guess have to
do it no girls do it again I think that
most of the girls know it's a cost
benefit of them every single one of them
turning off when someone goes out like
what's costing me to keep you lighter
especially at the start well because you
said that if they turn it off yeah but
you usually they'll at least play the
game they'll allow it to go through a
little bit I mean the the main thing
that everyone should take away from this
is nothing to do with the show it's the
sheer power of whoever's in charge of
operations and logistics that ITV is it
because nothing erson really needs to be
working it Tesla SpaceX because they
have the most difficult job in all of
television they've just got a really big
Gantt chart or like a Trello board or
something unbelievable yeah can you
imagine how optimized it it's gonna be
like Minority Report oh I bet they've
got six screens and yeah yeah but it's
about a rise anytime you see something
you see the Polish result of something
like the processes behind it like giving
a magazine so the thing is the thing is
with that like looking at take me out it
looks polished but it could look
polished without having to have this
incredibly difficult and nuanced so yeah
the fact is that they are able to create
14 weeks of programming in 16 days yeah
that's impressive incredible frolics
multiplying people out to different
wouldn't believe that probably that that
person's when we start thinking like
this is a really tight schedule
it'll it'll work as long as no one goes
and gets language stuck
central reservation somewhere and
choices backup for timing so but it all
worked on yeah it did all work and I
survived and you still had sex with the
girl who you who luck out blacked out
you back to your art turned a light fair
though i turned the light off
don't me there's a black house everyone
so yeah yeah so that was a redemption
so would you do it again take me out or
would you do something similar again I
imagine you weren't doing it to find the
date though from the cell not not at
that it was just Yolo actually that's a
question for you so love island and take
me out both have this outcome associated
with it all I care
they're both like trying to couple you
up with someone hmm was that what you
actually wanted out is that is that what
anyone wants a strategist doesn't know
some people some people do but some
people just want the exposure because
with people on the most recent series of
the tentative love island work people
were like I've come on here to find love
I just think the bollocks [ __ ] right
no no it's much easier to find love like
the local pub to find love in the
library yeah there is a there's a
program that's going to be coming out
soon within the next year that I think
will highlight exactly how little love
island is actually searching for love a
little the people and love island
associate to look they're not looking
for love on love ah they're definitely
not looking for own take me out but the
amount of failed dates that occur on
take me out I think is a good identifier
of the fact that we are a lot more
incompatible than we think
hmm you think if take a run and girl of
the right age who broadly looks
attractive and take a random guy that
she has verified is attractive by not
turning a light off and he's verified is
attracted by not turning hers off you
think well how hard can it be
look at the outcomes watch the dates on
taking me out more I would argue if you
did an analysis and if anyone would like
to please do so more than 50% of the
data
taking out will be disasters I can
finish up with one of them saying that
they're not interested in the other one
I suppose the only commonality with the
people on taking out is that they at
least don't mind the idea of being on TV
hmm but then there's a lot of them
another good thing about taking out is
because it's quite highly produced it is
and it's so intense it's a really good
unwrap for being on TV
mm-hmm so hi I'm not with fire isn't it
I have not been on taking out my
capacity on Long Island would have been
severely reduced is there very like fear
provoking in entrance into the show so
tomorrow the main thing that weird about
being on TV is that you need to put
during interviews with the camera either
down the pipe or to an interviewer you
need to put the question in your answer
and that's such an alien thing to do so
someone will say to you so Chris tell us
what you think about your date go so my
date today was bla bla bla bla bla bla
after we almost it was yes yeah so you
have to put that in and that just feels
so [ __ ] alien why is that because
they don't want the interviewers voice
to come in they know let's just have you
speaking so you need to frame the
question within your answer so they want
to prop they want to stage and prompt
the content without someone going to a
group um yeah
yeah and they wouldn't have it written
or whatever it may be so yeah that's
that's part of it but yeah deserve
there's a show that's gonna be coming on
within the next year or so which will
highlight I think a big difference or a
big issue with existing dating shows
like love islands is not people looking
for love it's like their very very best
it's next year's relationship Island
like yeah who the [ __ ] like I don't
think there's well I know for a fact no
one I've season one still together
there's one or two couples off season
two that's still together one or two
couples off season three they're still
together in season four words like
dropping like flies right so it's not
people that are looking to love it's
people that are looking for a
relationship that can be a springboard
for the station or traffic down there so
what they want man generally everyone
[ __ ] traffic yeah by the way proper
fitness calm for all of your training
and transformation needs traffic I had
very similar tolerances when I was on
appointment
it was almost but it was nearly as
pointless as you've both been on TV we
need to get you on TV fine if anyone
would like to feature Youssef on a TV
program a documentary about Arabs or
something know what I think it'll be
most fun the three of us being on TV go
fine but we kind of I'll be right now
probably we have the remote on camera TV
video guy Dean has brought more cameras
in this room that there wasn't the
entirety of take me off thank you very
much for watching if you've got any more
questions about taking out there will be
a new season coming up soon this is not
in associate as you may have guessed
this is not an association with ITV are
taking out I don't think I've got very
many friends left there now but if you
want to find out about the application
process I've actually had emails from
people asking me to guide them through
the application process to live Island
thinking about just doing a coaching
course or Chris coach fine but that's
taken but I suppose you've got a problem
with Coe and dot biz and those kind of
things
here's one you you you seem to think
that people want to write in like tim
dot blog it's cuz no one hugh types of
the URL and nobody okay so why is your
URL like a nine miles longer than it
already is what do you mean just like
propane fitness fitness fitness will
have protein dot fitness we've got all
of Chris because I think often of course
we have you got Pedro Payne fitness
probably you'll be in negotiations with
some guy a little high we want to buy
propane propane podcast calm and the guy
replied saying if it's a six-figure
offer I'll entertain how are you
[ __ ] you who are you you who are you
expecting is going to set up propane
podcast yeah isn't that the only other
person that could possibly do that
sometimes like reselling fuel for
barbecue
and does it cost about the middle yeah
it's a very low people run that
barbecues all right let's about this you
take podcast you say anyway okay bye
[Music]